today we're talking about a new podcast
a new member of the google cloud family
and some tips for keeping your data safe
i'm kelsey and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news we're pleased to launch our
startup stories podcast available on
youtube google podcast and spotify
each episode features an intimate
in-depth conversation with the leader of
a startup using google cloud with topics
ranging from technical implementation to
brainstorming ideas over glasses of
whiskey the first 11 episodes of season
1 are already online so go check them
out data studio our self-service
business intelligence and database
product is now a google cloud service
enabling customers to get data studio on
the google cloud terms of service
simplifying product acquisition and
integration in their company's
technology stack
learn more about what this means for
security your business intelligence and
how to get started on the blog as
enterprise and public sector cloud
adoption continues to accelerate having
an accurate picture of who did what in
your cloud environment is important for
security and compliance purposes
logs are critical when you are
attempting to detect the breach
performing forensic investigations or
exploring ongoing security issues
these five must-know cloud logging
features can help customers create logs
to best conduct security audits
learn more on the vlog if you want to
read more about these announcements or
see a full list check out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you